okay for people joining this livestream
this morning we are talking about wiki
data data hook up to wiki data and
connecting to our entity system and
other things okay so where have we
reached last time we were talking about
some okay so I say it's don't need to do
this um okay so with external identifier
well should I look at the design first
because what we discussed is that this
would be it's not wiki data ID this is
simply the wiki data service and that is
its description right for this entity
correct right okay um okay so let's take
a look here this belly with us here yep
okay oh I see that's an interesting idea
so you're proposing we lost all the
colons now that wasn't what I had in
mind but you're suggesting it's a
service name followed by what why would
we have I'm confused here
oh it's properly identifier okay so this
is an entity type but why is that what
is that I don't understand what the
entity type is here for wiki data does
it have an entity type descriptor in the
case it would just be Vicky's data so
just say wiki data and then it would say
the name of the thing yeah correct
okay and what's the artist deal there
musicbrainz has various identifier types
and other services do that too and in
musicbrainz case there are ten like
music brains work recording album and so
on so it's it is tinnitus that is it
just sort of
convenient coincidence in this case that
the musicbrainz services happen to
correspond to things that we would think
of as entity types but other other
identifier types may have different
services that don't necessarily cause an
awesome question yes and it's correct
and this might be somewhat subjective
how this is done
so for each service we would have to
study what the best system would be in
that case well hold on hold on hold on
to me using the capital letter thing
there would indicate that there's some
kind of alignment with our built in
entities but I mean my suggestion would
be that that's the way that we would
indicate that that this is well I don't
even know if that's true I mean that
this is a musicbrainz artist that is
aligned with our artists built-in entity
is that what you have in mind that's
hopeless you say is that right so I mean
we don't we don't have the entirety of
musicbrainz in our system fair enough
then that I have to say I think what we
should do I like the idea of lower
casing it to make it less definitive
okay and just having the lower case
service name generally Wiki data : and
then whatever it is um and you know this
case where the three things spaced out I
wouldn't be a I wouldn't be horrified
but just a column between each of these
wiki data : books google books ID :
whatever isn't that that would follow
our current convention in terms of how
we're doing
entity type entity type stuff right if I
do
oh no we're great to say we don't have
Collins okay well so no but okay okay
fine I'm wrong I'm wrong okay so so this
doesn't okay so I like your idea that we
would go kind of you know name of
service followed by
yeah I mean I think this is fine just
get rid of the artists wood or if there
is has to be an artist have it be
lowercase there musicbrainz artist and
then the beetle it's simple and I think
I think by prefixing it that way we're
kind of making it clear that it's some
kind of thing that's deep inside some
other creature and if it has to be an ID
then it would just say which either say
wiki data and then it would give the
description label or it would say wiki
data ID and then it's just the ID if
there isn't a description does that make
sense so we discussed that for a moment
and we're not sure whether we want this
ID there because if you see in an
scientific article it's citing a DOI it
doesn't rip report after that ID no it
just gives the ID the X oh no no I
understand that I understand I'm saying
okay so I see so you're saying do I
might be an example you just give the
DOI yes right but if the DOI okay so the
real point is if there is a description
of the article look I think DOI is an
ISBN of both cases where I could argue
that we should actually always expose
the actual identifier because their
story is that their identifiers
understand what I'm saying so that what
we do many of them are not giving the
bayard I understand that I understand
that so if what we said was do I
and then whatever it is some number and
then paren and then the label if there
is one or something like that but but so
something like DOI or ice bien in a
sense the number is the story it is an
ID
whereas wiki data we are talking about
pointing to an entity I'm not sure I see
this distinction that clear well it's
because people quote do eyes they don't
quote wiki data
no no Hugh
humans quote the Oh eyes they print them
in papers and stuff like this whereas
humans don't quote wiki data IDs because
it's too new
no no no no they won't
no they won't just like they were I
wouldn't expect people to quote our
internal IDs for entities they'll simply
point to the entity in some computer
poor form in a notebook or something
like that and they won't expose it I
mean I think the whole point of a DOI as
its name suggests it has the word
identifiers in it
ISBN has the has the word number in it
so my criterion would be what's that
okay that means so we could curate in
which case do we think it's more the
identifier thing that's important and in
which case that's what I'm suggesting
yeah I mean I'm suggesting that it is
like musicbrainz may even have an ID or
an orchid for example has an ID it is an
ID it's main event is its ID and it
could have a age that's John Smith type
thing for an orchid but its main thing
is that there's an ID and musicbrainz
what would that be I don't know because
I don't know enough about the structure
of that if there's a musicbrainz ID if
it's an ID then I think in the case of
musicbrainz this case where it's
musicbrainz artist and it has a label
the Beatles then I think that's what we
use if if on the other hand it's an
unnamed you know if it's prints with an
unprintable character and it's only by
the you know by its UUID then we got to
give musicbrainz
you know artist ID and then we give what
it is that will be my suggestion in
other words some
most of the time what you would see okay
the things which are primarily IDs as
opposed to primarily content would
expose their IDs right so in other words
it would be ISBN bla bla bla bla bla and
then if we know what it is we say paren
you know I don't know what it is you
know gone with the wind or something
right
if we don't know what it is and we just
leave the ISBN and as Michael says there
are unallocated ISP ends which we can
just treat as war ISP ends right there's
no other choice right there's a little
bit also two opposite like at least
theoretically services where there is
not a predetermined fixed number of
they're in quote IDs where you can send
anything like in chickies mmm-hmm but I
understand that's the difference between
entities and things like molecules which
we don't consider to be I mean we can
write to be entities and and then
there's a whole zoo of other ones now
external identifier seems to me okay so
the issue is this what point okay so you
type in random garbage for an external
identifier but one of these ones that
has I mean even wiki data or any of
these where there's a you know let's say
you make up a UUID for musicbrainz and
it's a UID that doesn't exist at what
point is that determined when you make a
request for that service okay
so otherwise it can sit there as a
symbolic you know here's this random
ISBN that hasn't been allocated yet
correct
oh it seems reasonable to me I mean
there might be a way I mean I could
imagine like like for these the you know
there's a server transaction that
determines whether we know about that
entity in these cases we might want some
something that checks does the entity
exists right and it's possible that you
type in an ISBN okay let's say you type
in an ISBN how does it resolve what the
name of the book is to put it into the
entity you would have to write a service
I would argue that what we should do is
this okay you enter one of these things
it tries to do a server transaction it
tries to resolve it
if it can it indicates that it's
resolved otherwise it has some
indication that it didn't resolve I
agreed we should have this functionality
but it should not be dead before
behavior why because you might want to
protest a million of them for service
some reason then you're not interested
in this additional information and it's
it's costly to get it thinking maybe we
can have an option to external
identifier that says don't go that
bother to get it because I think that's
the unusual case in other words if we
say Explorer identifier you know delayed
or something then it just sits there and
you can manipulate it and it only
resolves when it has to otherwise it
tries to resolve and give you a nice
print form but on the other hand usually
a function returns them and the
assumption is that the function does the
right thing and then you continue to use
them so it would be a vase to do
something if you already know they're
valid once we know the valid we can tag
them as valid I don't know how but if
you like the information scheme that you
just mentioned that you weren't mostly
as the display one I would mostly like
it as a computational part of a data set
you mean when we compute common name or
something my concern is when the thing
is okay so you say when it's generated
programmatically it's going to come back
resolved I'm like what's that unresolved
know resolved as in when you compute it
program at when you compute it by doing
some kind of wiki data search or
something oh it come back as a resolved
thing the only case where it isn't is if
you say let me probe the space of is B
ends and see what's been allocated right
well in that sense of programmatic
generation it would not be resolved by
you know from the start like let's take
you eyes you might have some big tech
fires with tens of thousands of things
and you want to protest this big tech
file so you don't want for it
with them to go out your gadget because
you might be I understand so what
function could get it I mean we could
have but there are two things get it and
edit into the scene toward eyes
formatting and get it as a data service
to all information I understand ok so
let's take a look for services other
than ok for external identifier what are
we expecting this services associated
with external identifier to be in
general do you understand what I'm
asking
you've got an external identifier Tony
you understand the question no ok well
let me repeat it
ok you've got an external identifier
there's certain questions you can ask
about that external identify those
things you can do with the external
identifier right am I making a sense
they could have static properties yeah
well no they could have okay but they
could have dynamic properties that is if
you want to do a look up on something
how do you do the lookup let's say the
external agent fire is an ISBN and you
want to find who the publisher was no
that's a bad example because coded in
the ISBN but let's say we wanted no
gumption for that right I mean that's
why we have something like wiki data
data that it can work with wiki data
external identifiers fine you want to
have external identifier magic we also
have a bunch of other so I don't know I
mean I'm I'm asking the question just
like we have services which have certain
service requests built-in maybe with
external identifiers
given an external identify there's
certain obvious requests you can make
could go beyond the pure you know these
ones here I would see the reverse
instead of external identify or doing
the work I think its existence should be
propagated to existing services so that
more and more services start
understanding them so the external
identifier should itself be very
lightweight well fair enough but the
services are you know entity value
basically what about information
yeah that's possibility that that could
do something with this just like it does
with ours I agree that that's
interesting
yeah I agree that's interesting but but
let's let's understand in terms of what
are we calling them external identifier
services or something what are we
calling you know we've got a list of
external services that's part of the
service connect framework what are we
calling the things which are you know
like musicbrainz and do is and so on I I
would call them after the service full
of followed by data like musicbrainz
data do i oh no no no no you're not
understanding my question it's not all
external identifier types returns that
with external identifiers type this is
the list okay okay alright fine fine so
then then then on the on there would be
a guide page called external identifiers
types right right and that on that guide
page ok great great so for each of these
we would list just like we do for our
entities we would list a certain set of
properties right so these were pages
similar to an entity type page external
identifier type would be have a a
documentation page like an entity type
right
in fact both of these you mean it into
the ends of sub videos probably sub
values but but or entity value
properties but I mean things that you
can yeah you know but I'm just asking
how house talk to really you call for
them I would say it I would say sub
values and then in other words here for
instance you know an ISSN I don't know
what you know so information of okay so
first we have is there a wrapper for
entity types there is no wrapper
it's simply oh I see I see I see I see
so the obvious thing to do just like
entity just like we can just say entity
of city right and that represents city
entities if I'm not mistaken right we
could say external identifier of issn
and then we can say information of that
does information of this
give the properties okay probably should
right does that make sense yeah so if we
want to use just the entity wrapper to
represent the type right we have
formally revealed that design okay I
think it's probably a sensible idea and
then we can use external identifiers to
similarly represent that external
identifier type and then we can use
information on it to get properties yes
so what would be typical properties
apart from those static ones I haven't a
clue I mean I don't know it depends
what's in these databases I don't know
ISSN it's probably you know the city
where the periodical is published the
year it was first published the name of
the registrant the link to its website I
don't know I mean all the usual kinds of
things right I mean one so it would
basically be the type metadata
historical I don't know whether it's
metadata I mean it depends what it is
right I mean just like in the case of
wiki data you've got a full you know
Sparkle animal so to speak right where
it has where there are different
properties associated with different
entities and we're making sense yeah but
that's different are we talking about
the individual things inside that type
or about the type itself no we're
talking about the individual things
inside the type well okay the type
itself may have certain generic things
just like I'm sure every wiki data
entity has certain generic things you
can say about it right
every generic issn probably has has
things you can say about it in the case
of wiki data it's very diverse what the
entities can represent in the case of
issn it's not particularly diverse what
the entities can represent so most of
the properties are burnt in and fixed
yep it was given one one since a string
pattern that this is SM has to match
okay Tony I don't think that what Steven
singular they let's take archive so I
think Steven is singing on our source
submission date tidal present of
supplementary stuff into one right or a
given article or for booth okay for
given article its Coakley data and for
the type is what things you can ask
about yeah right right
now obviously I hope we're gonna have a
meeting about this again soon our own
internal type hierarchy stuff which I
hope is been making progress
because I think it's really important um
will be somewhat related to these things
as well like person you know versus
astronaut versus novelist and so on am I
making sense yes Tony
yes have that been making progress very
small preliminary work but we need to
conquer get start the engines on that
because that's an important thing one
interesting thing that came out of that
is that we now have a list of general
properties that means properties that
apply to more than one type and we can
use those properties in the second
argument of wiki data data say area
which is something that applies to 10 or
20 different types okay fine
but that's all well and good but I'm
more concerned about getting our own
knowledge base you know with the correct
hierarchical information that I am in in
in trying to you know dig through the
mess that's in wiki data and so on yeah
making sense and also this alignment of
types properties and entities with
swiggy data helps to show where are the
gaps learn ontology is fine okay all
right so let's go back here I think
we're agreeing then that what's going to
happen is we're going to have for each
so
we're gonna have a page for each
external identifier type that is
analogous to an entity page that lists
certain generic properties and and as
far as possible specific properties
although in the case of something like
wiki data the specific properties will
vary from nth from individual entity to
individual entity am I making sense yeah
yes okay and then we support something
like Association in data that if you
would all at once exactly exactly and
that would be something that we would
support generically for an external
identifier that and information should
probably work as well just like it does
for you know and in the same way as it
does for a built in entity and as Tony
has put up the last time we had to be
specified we had to get it in case there
are multiple providers of this data that
might not be a Hana plant mutually
consistent yeah I understand that I
would think it was in the external
identifier itself some kind of method
option or you could put it in the or you
could put a method option in the entity
value basically but fourth sub for a sub
there you called it's a little bit ugly
put the method in the sub value if you
really have to have it
so basically archive open close title
comma method goes to which those are the
most oval or something I would think I
mean do we think of a better way to do
it I mean okay so look what this is the
question is how much people gonna want
to change this right I mean why would
you change it it could it could be a
system option that it's a system opt
well exactly but I mean but what we're
going to have is a system servers you
know remember we've got system servers
which say which geoserver you're using
in all kinds of stuff like that I would
say that when we can put it in a method
option we should but the default for the
method option is some kind of system
server setting and that in cases where
you're trying to use a you know an
alighted sub value it's just going to go
to the default
Hey okay so you know we put a method
option in when we can but the default
for that method option is set by system
server setting so by the way just to
connect things um I I don't know where
the service connections have that same
issue of a default service it's a
question I'm certainly integrated
services do like for example in the case
of those connections are all only their
one to one there's only one okay fine
service fine that they are specifically
connection to a service sewer service
yes right okay fair enough so then then
what we are dealing with here is more
like the integrated services like web
search and so on which has a different
method options right we have a we've we
identify a default but the user can
specify exactly other yeah hmm so one
issue is Brad Ashby is inventory in the
system servers thing and we should make
sure he is aware of that as another
setting for system servers is what the
integrated services are using by default
and then what the external identifier
types using by default right seemed
reasonable I mean yeah it will increase
his list of system servers but I told
him it was going to get long I mean
here's bunch more okay all right so
let's take a look then so graphic design
wise we seem to be settled is that true
we'll be using lowercase B lowercase
okay okay so in terms of spacing here I
I don't know why the artist is so spaced
out from brains and just just put it it
just have it be a regular space and then
I think go ahead
should it be lowercase the artist I mean
completely yes because it has no it is
not the only things that get up a cased
would be our built in entity types I
would suggest yep okay so don't catch
the first letter no no no no no the
first though know that whatever look
archive wouldn't cap the
flatter because it isn't capped except
it will be capped in our you know
standard name name yeah okay fine but
but this is a human name which would be
whatever weird decoration they have for
their names does that make sense yeah
and whether we cap the the a for artists
I don't know but I think it probably
looks better to do that
anybody got an opinion about that I
prefer a lowercase okay
do you have an argument for why it's
similar to properties very obviously
used to sentence case okay fine okay but
then the word ID I mean that's wrong it
should be a capital I think yes yes I'm
kind of unless it's gone heed my end
okay fine yeah fine okay so basically
what capitalized would do in general I
think you know it's it's unless the
thing is a branded name with multiple
words which some of them will be like
the Library of Congress I suspect you
know will however that capitalizes yes
um
and in other words if it's a branded
name like authority ID I mean if that
was a brand you might cap it if it is
just a description you don't cap it yes
CAS registry number is capital fine okay
all right okay good now in terms of the
hover behavior and so on the it might be
that well sorry well I just
okay I know go ahead what were you going
to say I was gonna say I think we I
think it's something that maybe Tony
could move forward with and then after
interacting with it we could maybe
change our mind afterward but unless
there's something like bigger that you
were thinking of changing no I think
this is why is the greater than greater
than not present in the end
put here in other words if we know how
to get to it why aren't we oh I see on
hover it shows the great line goes down
great that's that's the right thing yeah
and shows the URL you're gonna go to
yeah I'm good with that
any problems anybody sounds good
okay coyote goat on our live stream is
asking why can't all these external that
data sources be baked in the existing
entity framework trust me we are
spending decades trying to do that when
they make sense but it's a jungle out
there and we want to give people access
to the jungle even though there have
been no roads built through it that's
not what they're supposed to say anymore
about jungles but anyway you get the
idea um so this is you know this is
access to the raw jungle and we are
doing our best to connect the jungle we
don't necessarily believe in everything
that's in the jungle so some of it may
be complete nonsense and you know we're
doing our best to curate everything
ourselves but that's a separate problem
okay okay atom fighters point yeah
generate properties call preamble inside
media files I don't think I think I
don't know whether I don't think
preamble is really the right term for
our what we are now I mean we're just
using it as an internal name generic
properties I don't think that will ever
be exposed but we will list out certain
things properties properties always
available include blah blah blah right
what is the metadata Association what is
that what is where the label and
description live I see um
but I don't understand you you what if
you provide a label and description and
they have nothing to do with the ones
that were in the underlying service I
think that's fine
so it overrides yeah you can simply
replace them okay so it should say here
other expressions like integers are also
supported for certain services for a
certain for certain external identifier
types right yeah okay so then what
you're saying there is that meta
overrides the the built-in ones which
will affect display and will affect sub
values specifically asked of the entity
over the external identifier correct so
it could be a pretty confusing situation
that you say metadata you know you you
call it a metadata you say an elephant
is really a rhinoceros in the metadata
other words the entity the external
object that is an elephant in wiki data
you are rhinoceros I giving its label as
rhinoceros is that correct yes but you
could make it up there you and tie to
say that it's enviously sure I
understand right I mean and I understand
it's a programmable system okay let's
take a look down at some of these things
the identifier what does that mean the
identifier system shall I edit this page
I mean that this should surely be called
I mean I think should we call it type
well the external identifier type is
what this is mm-hmm okay so other
expressions like integers are supported
for certain external identifier types in
the
we have identifier system type I'm
changing that to or oh yeah represents a
resource identified by ID in the
external identifier well I mean that
that's probably okay in the estern
identifier system Titan associates
metadata associates the metadata given
by the association matter with this
instance of the external identifier
object right because it's just it you
could have one is a rhinoceros one is a
tiger right you could have both the
elephants underneath but one has is
dressed as a rhinoceros and one is
dressed as a tiger correct yes I feel
like that's more of a detailed section
there it is yes such as in the sentence
that meta well this isn't perfect okay
let's not let's not it is similar to
image with which can have metadata
included in I know that that's given by
meta information arrow yes so there was
an open question whether we should
include the meta information using the
option or whether it should be an
argument I'm not sure I don't know how
common this will be to overwrite the
existing metadata
I think vile identifiers are supposed to
be stable the labels can change now and
then if data improves so there is the
meta data matter to this in
okay okay
all right now down here I don't
understand
okay type okay the raw so I think this
should be external ID isn't repeating
somehow they've got external from
yourself maybe so
alright okay well but you can't override
that or if you can override the label
right you see what I'm saying and I
think if you should be able to say here
see that's not right because here what
you want to say is you want to have
something that says external label
because you might want to get the
underlying label or is there not an
underlying label what is the underlying
label the only label that is there is
the one that's embedded in metal okay
but so then I don't understand that
what's it gonna display it's gonna
display something from the description
field it's going to display label if
available and the ID otherwise no no
that's not correct because in wiki data
there may be a description that you're
going to use or to display the result
see what I'm saying
you're not saying q2 you're saying earth
am I making sense but
the label has been embedded no I know
you mean oh wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait I think we speak
about Tristan are you they are to think
it's returned over the thing gets put in
I think Stephen you think indicates we
had comes back from something Tony think
somebody types it manually from the
beginning okay okay so includes the
metadata given by the association to
this instance okay so that means it
could come back I don't understand what
you're doing here I don't understand
this so I don't know this is a muddle
yeah let's say then Mickey leaders asked
about the children of Albert Einstein
then some external identifiers are
coming back and for convenience they
include the labels that were specified
at that point in time for the returned
IDs okay how do you change those labels
nodes if you want it you're telling me
so
that meta thing I don't think this is
right I think that should be in some
option okay you're saying you just want
to carry it around in the symbolic
object just so it's easy to format so it
doesn't have to do any kind of server
transaction or something to format
correct exactly okay but how do we do
that for our current entities they'll
get it yes and it's cached and it
requires server costs no no no no it
requires one server call as this does
right it requires one cervical when the
external identifier or in our case the
entity is generated one per entity if
your meta led mood abyss or calls yeah
yeah yeah yeah right but it's adding
words so what you have here is a model
because what you've got is something
where you could type it in you could
dress the the elephant in a tiger's
clothing you could that could come back
from the you don't know where it's
coming from you don't know what it is
right so
okay if what you are doing is saying
that matter thing is additional
information that how can that stuff be
used it can be used for computation as
well it's essentially a local override
of a server call but let's say you want
to redo the server call genistein what
I'm saying yes right so you want to redo
it so it says so somebody put the tiger
in there but you think it's wrong so you
want to redo it and re re assign labels
based on what was actually in the
external service database yes so there
was a function in the initial design
that was called McGee data update meta
information no no no no we did not want
something like that that is a total mess
okay we got to think through how to do
it right that's sorry that's not the
answer right so what you're doing here
okay so you've got um okay so let's just
think for a second so this is a cached
piece of information that is stored here
and something needs to potentially
update that cache right not quite if the
use of words I don't think there's
automatically know it and I understand
that I understand that but I think but
the trouble is you don't know whether
that came from
in other words certain properties upon
generation of an external identifier
which properties will be it will be
exposed in the metadata that returns
when the external identifier is
generated do you understand the question
which of these will you choose to put in
there when you're generating a label in
the description for this emigration not
the URL for example the URL there's
something that can be generated given
the type in the ID okay all right
so then we got a say normally matter
comes back with the label in the
description is that correct what's the
difference in label in the description
the label would be something like Albert
Einstein and description would be
physicist or movie or whatever no well
no no that's it but okay but but depends
it depends on the service and Vicky data
chooses to return label and description
by default and as my talk I don't think
this is the right way to do it I think
what we should do is to be explicit
about what that matter contains and to
say something like display name what do
we call it in entity store what do we
call the display name okay that's that
so that's the display name label means
the displayed name right yes okay so
then then description is very obscure so
what would that be in the case of an
entity storm
what is the analog of description a user
can define that property but nothing's
particular happens with it okay all
right so what do we think it really is
here is it a a description could be a
giant paragraph about the life and times
of your particular favorite tiger right
well but typically a sentence long so
that the two terms label and description
are not typical to are not just used in
wiki data but are common in different
ontology and meta anthologies okay its
course so yeah all right all right all
right so this is displayed name and
description is is brief description yes
creation yeah well it might be for just
and figuration in which case we'll just
say physicist it could say you know
inventor of relativity or something yes
which is it
physicists are known for and so on so it
can wait a second so it isn't merely a
disambiguation or on Smith you know
resident of wherever yeah so that the
minimal thing that it should do is this
Amba grade but usually does a little bit
more okay but but but you're saying we
have no control over it that is it is a
it is a thing generally label and
description would come from the external
source of the external identifier yes
but you could overwrite them if you
really wants it to exactly
so we have to make this point again I
think we're thinking too much on the
scenario where this stuff comes back
from something I did saying a fair
number of usage will be people do them
locally like what I said earlier you
have a thousand papers that you analyze
so you read them all and emptied them
yourself okay so what are you saying so
you're saying we have to have something
that goes out and so you could type in
label and description exactly I feel
like that to commence it now it's not
the heavy fine but but then then then
what happens when if you feed this thing
in ok so then then you need something as
you say that resolves the external
identifier updating its label and
description right that I was saying
earlier we need a function that operates
on and changes the sync
okay okay so in the case of wiki data
data arguably that could be the one
argument form COI wiki data data or the
external identifier
yeah well so arguably then what we
should do is we should have a thing
called external identifier data perhaps
which could be the non sub value form of
that could be a form that isn't a sub
value and contains method options and
God knows what else which has an
alighted form which is the sub value and
it could have a one argument form that
simply returns the processed external
identifiers that make sense yes
potentially this the service as the
first argument I don't think so I really
really don't know I think it's a detail
and I think it it and I think again it
will default from the system servers
list um okay I like this this is yummy
too but basically like if you call this
it's also very existing stuff and gets
all new one
if the server says less than bet lakh
you do something
exactly so that's the generic form here
and if you called that on a wiki data
thing it would do the wiki data thing
okay okay all right I'm good with those
things there by the way I have to go in
a few minutes and I think Michael does
as well yes I'm going to remind you in
two minutes
oh okay I like this this is good okay
those are small but very useful
improvements to our symbolic spark
okay okay all right so I think we're
good to go
then I mean we should look at this a
little bit more but I think we're good
to go in terms of how this works right I
think I need to play with it a little
bit in what he dare to search max items
all right so here if I say max items 10
okay so what happened here
Wiki data-id Amazon what the heck is
that somebody is somebody is playing
games there no that's it there really
are fairy chess pieces with strange
names like antelope and elephant and
giraffe what is why is this one I don't
know why the label is Amazon yeah but
why is it probably called an elephant
it probably has multiple names and this
piece is called an elephant because it
hops over two spaces or I don't know so
the URL here so this is what we would be
giving I don't understand then that you
you've said over there that you're going
to give something which is a URL that
you can go go to whereas this is giving
an external identifier symbolic form so
which is it
I'm not sure I understand okay over here
that there is a there is a canonical URL
that you can go to and wiki data to see
what it means right
yes but what we're doing on the roll
over here on the hover is we're giving
the symbolic form right yeah Billy who
decides yeah it's not implemented yet we
just finished it and I understand that I
understand that but in in in Billy's
version the new design is showing the
URL as opposed to our symbolic form yes
okay so which is it I think once you go
over the label which is a link you see
the link tooltip but if you go over
other places you could see the input
form I think that's super confusing so
instead of a link hand it would be an
arrow cursor or just a standard text
cursor because you're about to make a
highlight and you happen to be over
something the link but it does heaven
for me I don't see why this is anymore
the link than anything else
because I guess we should not lose the
ability to see the actual ID I agree
but so maybe what we want to do is to
have the hover so the question is do you
really need to show the URL
I think you see everybody in a at the
bottom of the notebook there's already
an indication value that will go wrong
which notebook so if you hover if you go
over the Amazon in stand area yes the
status area shows the link oh well then
that's fine then what we want to do is
this and we want to indicate in here but
this so then this highlights with a
greater than greater than and shows this
as a roll over okay and we're good yeah
it's done I'm saying so in other words
the roll over that the hover tooltip
would be the symbolic description which
is useful I think okay
the symbolic thing there yes honestly
the the most useful thing there is
probably well we can get both of them we
can give all of it for the time being
yes that's fine that's fine and then it
comes up with a greater than sign
although I don't stand how that works
without everything jumping
hover in the design document includes
the ellipses at the end it sort of chap
that's not gonna work when it's a word
like elephant it's not gonna work to do
that so I don't know where you want to
put the guy than greater than then we've
we've also had one minute Steven one
minute max meaning all right okay I
gotta go
see you guys soon bye bye bye bye thanks